Read the instructions.
You can pause and play using the space bar.
My stance is not nice there.
I think the floor was really squeaky.
It was kind of distracting.
And also just the softness.
Yeah, I lost my balance there.
I think overall my stances were just not very good today because of the mats.
But that's alright.
Yeah, I also lost my balance there.
I like lurched forward.
I think my stance was just fine today.
Yeah, I also lost my balance there.
But yeah, I also lost my balance today because of the mats.
I'll be back tomorrow for another one.
Alright, everyone.
I hope you all enjoyed watching.
I'm so happy that my channel has come to a end.